okay he took his hand back but there we
go
there he comes that d-pawn is marching
finally he feels he has full control and
he's hoping that black's pawn push the
only remaining source of hope for
napolita is not gonna lead anywhere
well they played now for four hours 44
moves could it also be that john sort of
he wants this game to last as long as
possible because you don't want to lose
a quick game right no exactly
i've been that many times myself
sometimes i'll move 25 i'm completely
lost and then i was just like okay uh it
looks bad obviously
it looks bad for the fans if they see a
quick defeat so okay here we go exactly
what we showed black gave up that pawn
to open up the white king
and black is currently three pawns down
wow yeah at least the white king though
less safe than it used to be
and against some fear in the back of
magnus's mind
i mean there's no perpetual even if you
capture the pawn right yeah i think you
can take the pawn safely you can move
the white queen safely
uh it looks like magnus going for his
queen you can even push the white pawn
safely but there we go the white queen
going as
close to the white king as possible
and resignation it's over magnus carlsen
is up by two points in the world chess
championship match after eight games a
devastating and brutal loss for young
no i mean
[Music]
does not want to sit by the board and
discuss this game
look at that it's oh it's brutal bad day
in a world championship match